oh boy um
oh ah oh ah oh
uh oh oh my god oh
hey ah
oh oh
uh okay hi
welcome to american truck simulator i've
been on a bit of a
of a simula oh my god
i've been on a bit of a simulator kick
lately so i thought i'd go back to like
the
simulator game that everyone unanimously
loves and i don't know why everyone
unanimously loves
this isn't even like euro truck
simulator which is the actual one that
everyone unanimously loves
this is just american truck simulator so
i want to get the most american looking
man
with the most american-looking truck
with the most american-looking logo
and i'm going to like call it
mark america there we go
playing module california used to sure
steering weld gamepad
or joystick for most realistic i have a
controller
i could hook that up right about now use
as mouse
my god they're slow okay oh my god the
simplest driving that
what do you think i am some kind of baby
you think you think you're going to give
me a toy for a baby
nah i'm here for the oh god
directly select the desired gear similar
in difficulty to
sequential gearbox yet more realistic
physical h shifter like g27 or g25 is
recommended
requires clutch
i don't have a clutch manually shift
gears up and down between the selected
gears neutral reverse is a little
difficult to master but you can reach
better driving performance and have full
control over the vehicles
yeah i'll do this because i actually
don't have a clutch so i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go with sequential because i
wanna do i wanna get this
if this is gonna
my god okay rat trigger to accelerate
left trigger to break
left bumper to shift down right bumper
to shift up
okay we're about to get on the road
select the city you want to start in
well i guess i i better do you know
good old law saying although i uh hey oh
driving a truck in los angeles do you
want to walk yes
please dear god oh wow look there it is
is that yes where is this oh i know
where this is okay continue
last you have a chance to experience
your dream job driving a truck
your own transportation company is now
open for business
but sadly you lack the money to buy
truck well [ __ ] for now you'll have to
work for other companies as a driver for
hire
okay shouldn't open my company right
then and there i suppose your employers
provide you the vehicle that will cover
all expenses
don't let anyone down arrive on time
definitely don't let yourself down okay
to 42 print doc los angeles okay that's
probably in the garment district
current job close uh current job is
truck
thank you very much okay right
oh got it nailed it oh my god
kill me uh kill me now use your
additional controller to move the truck
try driving forward a few meters and
then stop okay
shift up wait my blinker
oh god that's also my blinker why is
that also my oh where am i
options options wait controls keys and
button controls
okay hold on can i ch can i not change
buttons buttons but here we go shift up
i didn't know that the blinkers were
part of this high beam oh god that's
gonna be important
oh no okay up is actually going to be y
and then down is x i've got another
button here so i'm just going to put it
on the high beams because
i just want to blast people as i'm
driving down the road that's pretty much
all i want to do
okay going back to drive okay so now
i'm driving uh
that's my horn okay we gotta fix that
that's that's awful that's
that's terrible that's the worst thing
i've ever heard how about air horn
because that's what i really want let's
get the air horn in there
that's that's what i need i don't know
what you're on about
[Music]
well you know what that's just gonna
have to do okay we're gonna
ry i'm turning right i'm leaving the
the place i have no idea
how to drive anything i know we're hit
i know i need to shift up i don't know
how many gears are in the truck there
could be 10
there could be 200 honestly i would
never know
can i get pulled over in this do i have
to stop for stoplights
what happens if i get in an accident i
am so
slow right now why there
what why am i going so slow i'm shifting
up time to make a delivery i press
f1 or joy back to look joy back
what about my back good job description
cargo i've got
15 000 pounds of clothes
how how is that possible
next rest shop in 13 hours
diagnostics okay damage oh
so i can do bad things to it okay
that's good to know okay press f1 or joy
back
i don't know take my joy back i guess
just shift up
all right we're gonna where's my map my
map my
my my map map where'd my map map me up
oh my god where my
map map map
okay we're gonna wait at the light
checking my mirrors
mirrors are good traffic's good
don't want to hit that oh my turn
shift up shift shift up shift
up how many gears do i have how many
queues do i have
i'm turning right everybody watch out
right is happening
apparently oh god here we go everyone
hold on look out oh my god
i take wide turns i'm so terrified why
am i termite oh it's really not that far
it's like right down the road
okay that's good to know
okay so being in 12th gear uh ain't
helping me much
okay i gotta shift a lot oh god watch
out buddy
watch out yeah you better stop for your
own good
my good all of our goods everyone's good
you shut up and get out of my way
still a wimpy baby horn i mean that's
that ain't no american
oh god i'm here for two prince i'm
stalled out and let me
shift that this is gonna be a [ __ ] oh
i'll go in this route
i'm here
i did it where you need it where do you
need it
skill truck driver will maneuver a tight
space when dropping off a trailer
however cargo safety is a priority if
you do not feel up to the challenge
negotiate with the dispatcher for a
backup place to park the trailer
okay let's do it i ain't about playing
it safe what do you think i'm some kind
of
[ __ ] you think i'm just some kind of
wimpy baby crying in a corner playing
with his toy trucks
no i'm american where you need it just
tell me where you need i'll put it right
in there
do i need to back up into that i
probably need to back up into that okay
let's uh how do i back up how do i go
back
how do i go backwards break reverse so
it is the same i'm probably just not on
the right
gear is all that's all it's just oh
reverse
reverse verse one
okay oh that's mighty speedy of you
okay so slow how we doing great hey you
feel that wall man you feel that
i feel you oh you're washing it that's
that makes
that makes sense oh i remember with a
truck you need to like
oh it's going wrong it's going wrong
it's going wrong stop please
stop okay you with a truck you need to
like
turn it a bit so that it can kind of
bend yeah like that and then
you can turn it to the back
and i i oh cut it cut it in
cut it in yeah you cut it yeah yeah you
cut
and then you how am i doing
hey bud you judging me
are you judging me right now you
shouldn't let me just yeah i'm
i was clear i was good which way am i
headed
okay okay okay okay
i'm getting my truck stuck
but okay how am i doing
beaut she's a beaut she's a beaut she's
a beaut
looking in the mirror she's a beaut okay
i'll go forward a bit
we're gonna straighten her out and then
we're just gonna ride this puppy back
and uh it'll be like nothing
error went wrong ever
okay so if i'm thinking about this
logically i need to go no no no rather
way
no no uh it's all wrong everything's
wrong i hate it this way yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay the little bump that's fine okay
okay i'm on target
just got no no no not that way not that
way yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay we're backing her up yeah okay i'm
pretty much locked on target bringing it
in
ah god i'm losing it losing it
don't know why i'm losing it but i'm
losing it
what did i hit the trailer is crooked
why is the trailer cooking
oh god what happened to it i can't see
ah going forward just need to straighten
it out just a little more
just a little more and uh and she's
gonna be a beaut you ever seen a beaut
you know what a beaut is all about well
this
this is a beaut yup yup
yup straight back straight back baby
straight back straight back
little less a little more straight back
little little more straight back
yeah yeah yeah okay and
i mean that's i feel like i'm in there
i feel oh god stop i
i oh little more okay all right let's
yeah oh my god unload baby deep
oh look at that freaking beauty
31 minutes
[Music]
okay free is the wind
free as the wind blows this is my
headquarters
i think that says [ __ ] headquarters
which is also true
it's pretty basic garage it may not be
much
much but it's a start unfortunately you
haven't got anything to park there yet
so there are no trucks inside
once you've earned enough money and
bought a truck you'll be able to move in
the
world freely and run your business from
here
good luck what good way
am i done see your progress i see my
progress look at my progress
skills what skills would i have i don't
know pick your next job okay get hired
as a professional driver no fuss
everything is private forward just pick
a bar
okay wind turbine tower
holy [ __ ] i gotta go to yuma arizona
why do they have 37 pounds of office why
do they have a wind turbine tower
worth of office supplies okay you know
what big bucks
big weight big bucks i'm gonna go for
the wind turbine tower
that's a distance oh i'm doing it i'm
here for the real deal
i gotta go to yuma i don't know where
yuma is all right let's let's
oh this is different okay parking brake
is on p
nope that's wipers of course oh i was in
neutral
of course we are out of here baby look
at that
cargo what did we hit
[Laughter]
my mama that's big i shouldn't have done
this
everybody get ready to say goodbye
i have new mail mail pardon me email i
have mail
brand new kenworth well shut up i don't
have enough money once i
deliver this i'll have money shut up i
gotta go
i only have so much time get through
this light my it's green
it's time for me here we go
left turn oh my god oh my god oh my god
how wide am i oh
it's fine it's fine hit that curb it's
fine it's fine
get out of the way or speed up or
something i don't know
i don't know if the distances are
completely accurate but it says i gotta
go 247 miles
and typically when when i have to go 247
miles
that takes a long time so
i don't know how much this is gonna take
up stop stop
you go away let's get her up let's get
her up
yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah gears
grade gears good gears buddy good
gears i gotta like go also did time just
go backwards or something
or is that time when i reached my
destination what time is now 10 41
oh my god okay so the speed limit here
is 30 and i'm going 33
can i speed am i allowed to speed
i don't know if i'm allowed to speed i
almost wish i
had gone automatic but i think the
dynamics of shifting is really what
gives the real experience here
and it makes everything just all that
more interesting and that's what this
game is
interesting you know when i was uh i was
building decks i
i would ride in uh my bosses um
it's like a ford f-650 it's
barely it's one step down from a semi
uh because you know we had a whole lot
of wood
and lumber so a lot of supplies but for
some reason sitting in the bed
of that truck or not the bed sitting in
the in the
with a cockpit is that what it's called
i don't even know the cockpit of the
truck just instantly put me to sleep
every single time i don't know what it
was about it
whether it was like the rumbling of the
engines or just that seat was so
cushiony or the fact that the suspension
on this
it had suspension on the truck itself
but also suspension on the seat so the
seats kind of bounced
like put me right to sleep i think that
if i ever wanted to
recreate that effort all i would need to
do is just get like a a springboard put
it on the bottom of that bed
maybe a water bed that probably put me
to sleep water bed still a thing anymore
does anybody do what weed
weed oh god i gotta stop weed
bear get out of the way everybody else
i'm about to
turn up the gears
never mind it shouldn't have gotten in
this lane watch out
shut up if this ain't the law saying can
i turn my
goddamn wipers off how long have those
been a stop
the truck i stop a lot sooner than i
thought i would think i would because
usually my experience with seeing trucks
stop in videos and stuff is they they
annihilate everything and that's how
they stop
they don't actually have built-in brakes
their brakes or other cars
okay i think no i'm not turning right
here that was almost a mistake
i need to get on on the five
i know that number is a good number this
way
not left this way here we go this is the
correct entrance
correct oh god really hitting that
guardrail there that's fine
here we go baby now we're getting it
five hours left on this trip
we i'm gonna be emptying a 830 mile i
don't even need to fill up on this trip
it's open road baby
it's oh yeah look at this watch out
everyone else
you know there's something about la that
this just is not getting right
is uh that this um you know is uh not
trafficking um the problem here is
there's no traffic so
really the my fears of driving in la are
alleviated because there's literally no
one else here
and also the construction is minimal
also things are green which is also
another oddity like that
that's pretty peculiar um
the way that that is i'm going too fast
i'm going to get
pulled over if i keep doing that right
am i right is that how this works
i don't know is that so what happens
cruise control
set it cruise i'm cruising baby yeah
all right this is epic man okay 17th
gear that seems nominal
okay why the arrows like that do i need
to get it do trucks have to get over is
that a thing a truck could have to do i
don't
see that usually happening on roads
trucks usually kind of nowadays just
wherever they feel like
being is where they are oh my god 207
we're okay we're in
it's gonna be a drive wait no god why
would you have oh god please let me
through
let me oh my god go go go okay
oh my god we're fine that was probably
the most exciting thing that's gonna
happen on this whole road
i think this is it right
what would happen if i speeded just a
little bit what what would happen
what happened am i gonna get pulled over
what happened they're gonna be happy
oh i made it there a little earlier than
before that's good
right that's a good thing how many gears
this thing got
couldn't go faster right
i don't see any reason why not i'm not
gonna get pulled oh god a turn that also
that might be we're gonna take this baby
at speed let's see how she do
see how the handling is on this oh it's
like a
like a baby like a baby like a butt wow
like a oh stop all right i'm about to
pass
anybody there hope not i got blind spots
i'm driving blind look out
look out i got livery to make
nerds get out of my way
i'm on the highway eat my
dust and also my taint cause you all
suck and i've got it
in the bag where ah this is
my exit please oh i gotta make a loopy
loop
at least they got the los angeles smog
perfect look at that
localized to just in front of those
buildings oh this is gonna be
interesting
oh this is gonna oh this gun
[Music]
visit service view services enter
to service
all right let's do it again visit
service why
we don't need it services for chumps all
right let's get on the open road again
hey actually that jumped us forward hey
we're actually closer to our destination
so that that
that little trick worked out for us call
it a time skip you know
in the speed running world that's a
valuable exploit
and i am valuable you know red lights
are just suggestions right
here we go i'm sorry buddy
red light violation oh my god that's so
much money screw you
are you kidding me it was a left on red
it was perfectly legal
you should unlock differential during
regular driving or you risk it stan okay
unlock
i don't know what differential means i
know like differential equations
is a thing but i doubt that's what's
happening now
okay it's the second lawyer hey buddy
watch it hey
get your ass out of the road here we go
nice and this is probably how turns
should be taken
oh my god oh my god trailer damage
well it's not my trailer so who cares
all right back on the open road now
we're really gonna get it
whereas before we did not really get it
but now
we are real oh my god i'm on there
there we go now i can see big curves
coming up down the road which is a bit
more important
also just for for my pick and fights
just because i can i believe that
maps should always be oriented up north
what engine malfunction is it but i was
at service do you mean they didn't
fix it what waste station bypass service
you can bypass
oh good i watch out buddy oh my god oh
my god oh my god okay yeah
thanks [ __ ] my fault but i'ma blame
you
anyway i'm gonna pick a fight because
i believe maps and gps should always be
oriented north
because it gives you a fixed points of
reference all the time that
a gps like automatically adjusts to
where your car is heading
you lose your orientation and therefore
you get less of a of a sense of
you you don't know where you are so
that's like why i'm really good at
directions i think is because i always
trust
maps to be oriented north so i always
know where i am in orientation to what
north is and when i'm outside of the car
because i know what
north is and i generally can see it
around me you know i i kind of get a
i'm going pretty slow is there like uh
something wrong with my engine or
something is there like an engine
problem do i got engine troubles
is this just a hill what's going on here
what's the what is happening guys i mean
usually i drive
my car and the check engine light is on
for years so i like
wha why would i do it for a truck just
seems rude
see speed limit 70 you see 70 i don't
care if there's a separate limit for
trucks
i don't apply to me i'm above those laws
not all laws but some and many
i am above excuse me passing the
left on your left
pardon me i did not
i did not you screw yourself i did not
oh i don't have an 18th gear anymore by
the way that gear is now just
dead all right cool here we go let me
turn my high beams off
on are they on off i it's day i can't
really tell
so i'm not a hundred percent sure but uh
just keep flashing them until i figure
it out are my high beams on yeah
i don't know shut up all right whatever
i'm making great time by the way i'm
only 19 miles away
but 31 minutes so i'm guessing there's
going to be some navigation once i get
to the location
and probably some backing up and
probably some maneuvering or whatnot or
what have you
i don't know things get a little
unstable above 80.
this wind turbine should help out i mean
i'm practically generating power as i
drive
so it's kind of infinite but it excuse
me a lot of
here it's my exit everybody's my exit
my exit is here here's my exit okay good
good stuff i discovered yuma which is
fun
because that's where i'm going i don't
see anyone
so it's probably fine to make a
california stop
oh my goodness oh i hit those signs a
bit but thankfully those don't deduct
from my paycheck
okay so now i'm starting to realize why
trucks take the turns they do like they
turn out first and then they turn in you
know
kind of stuff like that seems uh seems
to make a lot of sense nowadays
and you better you better believe i'm
gonna park this
exactly where you want it in exactly the
way that you
want here's my turn signal because i
should get a bonus for that
you deduct pay for bad moves you should
give me a bonus
for good moves all right here we go
there's my arrow
oh my goodness
at these low gears i better just up and
down two at a time because
doing it otherwise is just too too
cumbersome
i don't want my gear shifting to be
cumbersome no i'm turning
you [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] pizza house i
will destroy your house i'll burn all
your pizza i'll eat your pizza in front
of you and then i'll
leave you a bad yelp i can't move
coming for you pizza man i'm coming for
you you saw my turn signal there my
headlights on
can't tell all right and then in here is
my delivery
rail export perfect
perfect excellent great i'm here
all right where you need it give it to
me
okay can confirm i saw where that was
over there
perfect okay all right someone order a
wind turbine
all right am i straightened out here yep
shram
it's just a little inch forward a bit
okay now we're gonna
we're gonna get into old reverso
uh this way that's
not the right way that's kind of the
right way
so i need to turn this way
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah baby that's fine hmm i'm
not quite getting it
oh my god oh my god
i've somehow wedged it closer and closer
to this
angle and it's like that's not what i'm
trying to do buddy is it
that's that you know it's not what i'm
trying to do
wait oh i think i understand what i need
to do
i definitely understand what i need to
do
okay so i need to get here and i need to
jackknife myself this way
and that
am i complete genius
the answer will not surprise you
oh no wrong way god damn it i did it
again
okay this way
yes this way okay so what i'm trying to
do okay damage
20 it's fine so i'm trying to do is i'm
trying just to scoot it
a little bit at time and i need to
orient it
more every time i scoot and it'll get
there
eventually because i keep scooting it
over
yeah uh-huh yeah okay i'm straightened i
finally got it in the correct no
actually
it stopped being correct for some reason
how many times can i do the same exact
thing and expect it to be
any different
what am i hitting what am i what am i
hitting what am i hitting
oh
okay okay maybe this will help maybe
this will help me understand
no god i did the same thing
stop
maybe i just need to get out and try it
again
maybe that's what i need to do okay i am
now back to square
one guys i've made it back okay so what
i what i want to do
is i want to go straight a bit i want to
turn my wheels
fully fully over and i want to
maneuver myself this way
i know engine malfunction oh god no no i
oh my god
okay okay turn all the way this way
all the way this way what no
that turn all the way
okay what i'm gonna do is i'm going all
the way back out
and i am going to back the whole thing
in hello hi don't mind me
i've been here for a [ __ ] hour okay
we are
in business you don't believe me
but trust me when i say we are
in freaking business baby
am i going to hit that oh my god please
tell me i won't hit that
oh it's so close that's precari
no no oh come on it's right there come
on push push baby push
push oh whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa we're free we're
free we're free okay wait hold on
now it may you may be like well you're
just in the same place you were i'm like
no
you fool you fool of course i'm not
of course i'm not in the exact same
place i'm in
a much a better place
right you know it baby oh my god
oh my god oh my god i am
getting it i am in it to win it i am
in it we're so close we are so close
my guys and my gals
we are so close
what what did i hit oh what am i how am
i
getting farther away from this doesn't
make sense what
is happening
oh my god oh my god
oh my god this is it oh god wrong way
again but
i it's it's like overriding instincts
that i have to relearn
to get this to my brain to not
screw up the direction and that's the
problem like because i keep
my brain keeps screwing up the direction
that the wheels need to be because
reverse and then
the hinge whole thing it's it's all
excuses i'm making excuses guys
but these excuses are all i need to
slot this baby right in to where it
needs to go
yes look at that lineup look at that
line look at that yes
boom
oh my god oh my god
i did it i did it i did it i did
hazardous cargo yeah give me the [ __ ]
oh my god explosives please give me that
oh my god
i'm done i'm done i did that i nailed it
i
did everything and i learned and that's
the most important thing i learned i
learned how to maneuver
perfectly and no one can question that
through trial and error alone
and perseverance and the sweat of my
brow
other places let me know what you
thought down the comments if you want
more of this i probably won't
but you know you can scream at the void
there's a like button there that might
do something
i don't know thank you let me know if
there's more simulator games that i
should play because i'm having fun with
them taking them kind of seriously
anyway thank you and as always i will
see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
so